>>> IN OXFORD MICHIGAN, THE
15-YEAR-OLD MADE HIS FIRST COURT
APPEARANCE TODAY.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH FOUR COUNTS
FIRST DEGREE MURDER IN
YESTERDAY'S MASS SHOOTING, ALONG
WITH ASSAULT AND WEAPONS
CHARGES, AND A RARE COUNT OF
TERRORISM CAUSING DEATH.
THOUGH HIS NAME IS OUN THE
CRIMINAL DOCKET, IT WILL NOT BE
PART OF OUR REPORTING.
INSTEAD FOR A MOMENT, WE WANT TO
FOCUS ATTENTION WHERE IT BELONGS
ON THE NAMES OF THE FOUR YOUNG
MEN AND WOMEN WHOSE LIVES HE
ALLEGEDLY TOOK AND WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT THOSE LIVES AND IT SADDENS
AND SICKENS ME EVERY TIME WE DO
THIS BECAUSE THEIR STORIES AND
HONORING THEIR LIVES, WHICH IS
THE LEAST WE COULD DO, IS ALSO
THE MOST IT SEEMS ANYONE CAN DO.
IN ADDITION TO EXCEL BEING
ACADEMICALLY, TATE MYRE WAS A
VARSITY FOOTBALL STAR.
A FRIEND AND TEAMMATE TELLING
CNN HE WAS A GREAT PERSON, A
GREAT LEADER, SOMEONE THAT
ALWAYS WANTED TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE WAS OKAY AND INVOLVED
IN EVERYTHING HE COULD.
THERE IS A PETITION ONLINE TO
RENAME THE SCHOOL FOOTBALL
STADIUM AFTER HIM.
AS OF THIS MORNING, MORE THAN
48,000 PEOPLE HAVE SIGNED IT.
TATE MYRE DIED IN A POLICE CAR
ON THE WAY TO THE HOSPITAL.
HE WAS JUST 16 YEARS OLD.
17-YEAR-OLD MADISYN BALDWIN.
SHE WAS EXPECTED TO GRADUATE
THIS-SCHOOL YEAR, AND HAD
ALREADY BEEN ACCEPTED TO SEVERAL
COLLEGES, SOME WITH FULL
SCHOLARSHIPS.
HER FAMILY SAYS SHE WAS AN
ARTIST WHO LOVED TO DRAW.
WRITING ON SOCIAL MEDIA TODAY,
HER GRANDMOTHER SAID THIS
BEAUTIFUL, SMART, SWEET-LOVING
GIRL WAS TRAGICALLY TAKEN FROM
US ALL TODAY.
LEAVING A HUGE HOLE IN ALL OUR
HEARTS.
HANA ST. JULIANA.
WELL, SHE WAS JUST 14.
SHE PLAYED ON THE SCHOOL
BASKETBALL TEAM.
TEAMMATES TWEETING TODAY, WE'LL
NEVER FORGET YOUR KIND -- YOUR
KIND HEART, SILLY PERSONALITY,
AND PASSION FOR THE GAME.
THIS SEASON, THEY WROTE, WE PLAY
FOR YOU, HANA.
AND JUSTIN SHILLING, WHO DIED
THIS MORNING, WORKED AT AN
AREA-RESTAURANT CHAIN THAT
EMPLOYED MANY STUDENTS FROM
OXFORD HIGH.
THE COMPANY PUT OUT A STATEMENT
TODAY -- HERE IS SOME OF IT.
JUSTIN WAS AN EXEMPLARY
EMPLOYEE, DEVOTED FRIEND AND
CO-WORKER, CO-CAPTAIN OF HIS
BOWLING TEAM, AND SIMPLY A
PLEASURE TO BE AROUND.
JUSTIN SHILLING WAS 17.
SEVEN OTHERS, SIX STUDENTS AND A
TEACHER, WERE SHOT AND WOUNDED
YESTERDAY AND OUR THOUGHTS ARE
WITH ALL OF THEM AND ALL THOSE
FAMILIES IN PAIN TONIGHT.
YOU WILL NOT SEE THE SUSPECT'S
FACE ON THE PROGRAM TONIGHT.
BUT YOU WILL HEAR THE EVIDENCE
AUTHORITIES HAVE AS TO WHAT THE
SUSPECT DID AND SAID LEADING UP
TO THE SHOOTING, AND DURING IT.
AS CNN'S ADRIENNE BROADDUS
REPORTS, SOME OF IT IS
POTENTIALLY DAMNING, NOT TO
MENTION HORRIFYING.
>> Reporter: THE SUSPECT
APPEARED VIRTUALLY IN COURT, AS
POLICE DESCRIBED THE SHOOTING
AND HIS ATTORNEY ASKED THE COURT
TO ENTER A NOT-GUILTY PLEA ON
HIS BEHALF.
>> HE METHODICALLY AND
DELIBERATELY WALKED DOWN THE
HALLWAY AIMING THE FIREARM AT
STUDENTS AND FIRING.
RIGHT OUTSIDE THE BATHROOM, HE
BEGAN FIRING, JUDGE.
THIS CONTINUED ON FOR FOUR OR
APPROXIMATELY FIVE MINUTES.
THE DEFENDANT WENT TO ANOTHER
BATHROOM.
AS DEPUTIES ARRIVED, HE SET THE
FIREARM DOWN AND HE SURRENDERED.
>> THE SUSPECT'S PARENTS ALSO
WATCHING VIA VIDEO AS POLICE
DETAILED VIDEOS THE SUSPECT
RECORDED ON HIS CELL PHONE AND
HIS JOURNAL WRITINGS.
>> THE NIGHT BEFORE THE
INCIDENT, WHEREIN HE TALKED
ABOUT SHOOTING AND KILLING
STUDENTS THE NEXT DAY AT OXFORD
HIGH SCHOOL.
FURTHER, A JOURNAL WAS RECOVERED
FROM ETHAN'S BACKPACK ALSO
DETAILING HIS DESIRE TO SHOOT UP
A SCHOOL, TO INCLUDE MURDERING
STUDENTS.
>> Reporter: THE OXFORD,
MICHIGAN, SCHOOL STUDENT SHOT 11
PEOPLE TUESDAY, KILLING FOUR.
AFTER A MEETING WITH HIS PARENTS
AND SCHOOL AUTHORITIES EARLIER,
THAT SAME DAY.
WE WERE WITH THE PITMAN FAMILY
LEARNING ABOUT ONE OF THE
VICTIMS, TATE MYRE, FROM HIS
FRIEND DEVON.
>> TATE'S PROBABLY THE MOST BEST
PERSON I PROBABLY MEET BESIDES
MY DAD AND BESIDES GOD.
TATE WAS ALWAYS -- HE'S SMART IN
CLASS.
ME AND HIM USED TO JOKE AROUND.
ME AND HIM USED TO PLAY.
>> Reporter: AND THEN, NEWS
ANOTHER CLASSMATE DIED.
>> JUSTIN.
NO.
I KNEW JUSTIN.
>> THAT WAS HIS BOY.
>> JAVON DESCRIBED CALLING HIS
DAD DURING THE SHOOTING.
>> I WAS WHISPERING BECAUSE I
DIDN'T WANT THE SHOOTER TO HEAR
ME AND MY CLASSMATES AND MY DAD
WAS JUST ASKING WHAT'S GOING ON?
WHAT'S HAPPENING?
AND I TOLD HIM IT'S A SHOOTING.
SOMEBODY'S HERE SHOOTING UP THE
SCHOOL.
AND THEN, HE TOLD ME HE SAID,
OKAY, I'M ON MY WAY.
>> WHY YOUR DAD?
IS HE YOUR SUPERHERO?
>> YES
.
>> YOU CAN'T SAVE YOUR KIDS.
THAT'S DEVASTATING.
I'D RATHER BEEN THE ONE THAT GOT
SHOT THAN MY KIDS.
>> Reporter: AFRAID FOR THEIR
LIVES, OTHER STUDENTS SHELTERED
IN THEIR CLASSROOM.
BARRICADING THE ENTRY.
REFUSING TO OPEN THE DOOR FOR
AUTHORITIES.
>> WE ARE NOT TAKING THAT RISK
RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: AND THEN, ESCAPING
THROUGH A CLASSROOM WINDOW
FOLLOWING THE TRAINING THEY
NEVER WANTED TO USE.
WHEN POLICE TOOK THE SUSPECT
INTO CUSTODY ON TUESDAY, HE
STILL HAD 18 ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION.
TONIGHT, IN OXFORD, MICHIGAN,
FAMILIES ARE NOW LEFT WITH A
NIGHTMARE THAT FOR SOME WILL
NEVER END.
>> I TURN OFF THE LIGHT AND I
HAVE MY KIDS.
BUT SHERRY AND BUCK DON'T HAVE
TATE.
THEY'RE IN THE ROOM BUT THERE
SOME PARENTS THAT THAT ROOM IS
GOING TO BE EMPTY.
>> ADRIENNE BROADDUS JOINS US
NOW FROM OXFORD.
WHAT MORE ARE AUTHORITIES SAYING
ABOUT THE SUSPECT'S PARENTS?
>> Reporter: ANDERSON, WE
LEARNED THE SUSPECT'S FATHER
PURCHASED THE GUN THAT WAS USED
IN THIS SHOOTING FOUR DAYS
PRIOR.
EARLIER TODAY DURING A NEWS
CONFERENCE, THE PROSECUTING
ATTORNEY SAID THE SUSPECT'S
PARENTS COULD FACE CHARGES.
WHEN CNN PRESSED ASKING IF THERE
WAS EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THOSE
POTENTIAL CHARGES, SHE DIDN'T GO
INTO DETAIL.
BUT LATE-THIS EVENING, SHE DID
SAY IT IS IMPORTANT FOR GUN
OWNERS TO PROPERLY SECURE THEIR
WEAPONS AND I AM PARAPHRASING
THERE.
MEANWHILE, YOU SAW IN THAT
STORY, THE PITMAN FAMILY WAS
VULNERABLE WITH US.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW
WITH FORGIVENESS.
IF YOU WALK INTO THEIR HOME,
YOU'LL NOTICE THEY ARE
CHRISTIANS.
BIBLE VERSES HANG ON THE WALL.
JAVON PITMAN SAID HE IS GOING TO
MISS HIS TWO FRIENDS.
IT WAS TRADITION FOR HIM AND HIS
VARSITY TEAMMATES -- THEY ALL
PLAY FOOTBALL TOGETHER -- EVERY
THURSDAY, THEY WOULD MEET AT
TATE'S HOME FOR DINNER.
AHEAD OF THEIR FRIDAY-NIGHT
FOOTBALL GAMES.
AND THIS IS THEIR SENIOR YEAR, A
TIME WHEN THOSE STUDENTS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE CREATING THE MOST
MEMORABLE MOMENTS.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED INSIDE OF THIS
HIGH SCHOOL